here was reaction 2024 Republican
Presidential uh candidate and now my
Governor I know you stuck with me this
is really that's I'm sure this is
painful for you uh Governor Rhonda Sant
here you know Sean the thing about it is
is um us Floridians uh usually don't go
north in January here I am in Iowa it's
now single digits uh there's going to be
a big snowstorm coming through tonight
and tomorrow by caucus night they think
it could be
-20° with windchill even less than that
and you know I was down in Florida at
the beginning of the week for the State
of the State address uh when I flew up
to Iowa I actually I do own a winter
code in Florida I haven't worn it in a
while but I left it there so we're
getting my stuff I'm going to be ready
to go but we got a lot of great
supporters that
are I gave away all my winter close
they're gone I I gave it away I uh
wasn't planning on 20 below weather and
I'll be there with you on on Monday uh
all right let's talk about from your
perspective the state of the race uh how
important as Iowa to you uh I always
find Iowa a caucus system could be a
little funky New Hampshire allowing
Independence to decide you know what
Party primary they want to vote for that
makes that kind of puts a twist into
things your reaction to both of those
and then heading into South
Carolina well last night was a great
night for us I think that Nikki Haley
was clearly flustered and rattled
because she's uncomfortable being
confronted with her record I'm proud of
my record in Florida of beating the left
of delivering on my promises and I'm
proud of the vision we have for this
country so when that debate ended we had
people going to Ronda sanus.com uh
signing up to help more people been
going to the website to donate so that's
that's a great sign for us but here's
the thing Sean you're exactly right a
caucus is just different than a typical
election because it's about organization
it's about turning your people out we've
built an incredible organization I've
gone to all 99 counties uh I've answered
questions from Iowans all across the
state that is not necessarily what
Coastal media likes to see uh they think
you're spending too much time listening
to people I disagree with that that it
does pay off on caucus night now with
this weather I think the organization's
going to matter even more because going
out in negative 20 degrees uh unless
you're really committed to voting that's
an easy reason why you wouldn't want to
go so we've got that in place uh we're
continuing to gather more folks I've
done a number of events today Sean
people are coming out in big numbers
even in the weather we're going to do an
event right after this I got a big crowd
right now here in the De Moine Area so
people are definitely getting excited
about this race we've seeing energy on
the ground but Monday the story is
organization organization organization I
think we've done it right and I'm
looking forward to uh being able to take
that through I'm looking forward to it
but I'm not looking forward to the 20
degree below uh zero uh weather that I'm
going to be flying into assuming I can
get there uh with all the weather you
know it's very interesting um I was a
little surprised Governor I I had
confided in you and told you and many
other people I said it publicly for
years that I was going to get out of New
York I just want to play both Kathy
hokel and Andrew Cuomo basically saying
they don't want conservatives in New
York but I want you to answer under the
prism of you have a larger population
than New York you have half the budget
of New York your infrastructure is twice
as good as New York and your schools are
number one and your crime is half of
what New York's crime is uh with half
the money uh but just listen to what
these two Governors had said to
conservatives in the state and we're
here to say that the era of trump and
zeldin and molaro just jump on a bus and
head down to Florida where you belong
okay get out of town get out of town cuz
you don't re you don't represent our
values you are not New Yorkers their
problem is not me and the Democrats
their problem is themselves who are they
are they these extreme conservatives who
are right to life a pro- assault weapon
anti-gay is that who they are because if
that's who they are and if they are the
extreme
conservatives they have no place in the
state of New York so because that's not
who New Yorkers are then he said tax
Rich tax the rich tax the rich we did
well God forbid the rich leave here's my
qu I mean well first of all I'm not
anti-gay uh but I am Pro Second
Amendment I am proudly pro-life and I
just listen to that get on a bus get out
of town I mean you're you're you're
earning what 400,000 new Floridians now
including me a year um I got to imagine
you're pretty happy about
that and you know obviously the upper
income people save a lot of money money
because they chase them out but it's not
just that Sean I mean the number of
people that retire out of FDNY NYPD Port
Authority where do they go I mean some
of them obviously stay in the tri-state
area but a lot of them move to Florida I
mean we've got a massive numbers of
folks retired here who were active on
911 and responded to the Twin Towers so
uh you know they're getting New York
pension payments and they're spending it
in Florida and you're right we have half
the budget with much better results our
state government in Florida is the
smallest of employees per capita in the
entire country it just shows you the
people in New York are getting taxed for
your state government to waste that tax
dollars because we're doing better with
half the footprint but I also think what
you showed with hok and and Cuomo
there's this movement amongst the left
to try to demand a one-party State and
to try to weaponized government against
conservatives it's not surprising that
you've seen that with that line of
thinking I think it's really
dangerous yeah well I'll tell I thought
California was bad New York is just as
bad if not worse um uh and I'm still
getting asked questions about your
debate with Gavin Nome Governor thank
you for being with us hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else